un projet qui fait débat dans le cadre
de l'aménagement du futur quartier la
gare de la ligne 18 50 ans est un
dévoiement de l'ère des 91 est prévu
cette départementale fait la jonction
entre versailles et la vallée de
chevreuse en traversant guyancourt et
voisins le bretonneux
cette déviation s'effectuera en deux
fois deux voies en prolongement de
l'avenue de l'europe la route arriverait
alors depuis guyancourt et le
technocentre renault directement sur le
quartier de la bretonnière de
voisins-le-bretonneux les membres de
l'adav association de défense des
habitants de la ville vit chinoises
redoutent les conséquences de ces
projets on imagine un flux de
circulation qui sera très important avec
un tourne à gauche à hauteur du
campanile alors qu'aujourd'hui cet axe
de la d81 venant de versailles la
minière et à lanvallay vers la vallée de
chevreuse traverse directement le
carrefour ces modifications de
circulation s'accompagne de la
construction de 1300 logements d'ici
2030 sur l'ancien site de l'entreprise
thalès plus un parking de 800 places un
parking relais pour les gens qui
fréquenteront la ligne de métro imaginé
qui a à peu près de 4000 personnes soit
un tiers de la population de voisins qui
vont évoluer dans ce quartier où
convergeait vers ce quartier donc un
tiers de la population de voisins sur un
terrain qui fait fait hectares un
dixième de la surface de
voisins-le-bretonneux on imagine les
conséquences que ça oran l'adav défend
le contournement sud de
voisins-le-bretonneux qui était prévu à
l'origine de la ville nouvelle
contacté par notre rédaction la mère de
voisins-le-bretonneux alexandra rosetti
n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer sur le sujet